[Music]
hey you guys
this right here is my tomes of terror
show where i review books
okay
so this is what happens when i take
recommendations from people
uh i believe i think it was during maybe
one of our side track shows
that i brought up a book that i reviewed
a while back which i liked very much
called tender is the flesh which is uh
you know essentially about a future it's
a fable a feature where uh humans can't
eat animals anymore so they essentially
start breeding a certain type of human
to be slaughtered for meat and it goes
like way into the slaughtering process
so while i was mentioning that book
somebody in the comments don't remember
who it is but you know who you are i'm
sure
uh recommended hey if you want a really
gross ass book or like a really
disturbing book why don't you read this
one right here this book is called cows
by uh matthew stuko stoko i'm not really
sure how you pronounce his last name so
i'm sorry about that
uh so i noticed that this book was on uh
kindle unlimited for free like you could
read it for free and i was like what the
hell we'll give it a whirl i like some
gross [ __ ]
okay
now
this was a good book
but i'm gonna tell you right now this is
one of those books this is
gotta be
i mean if not the most disgusting thing
i've ever read
it's definitely up there like in the top
because i've thought i've i've read some
gross [ __ ] i'm not generally into like i
like extreme fiction
but i don't know i i kind of feel like
sometimes there's a very fine line with
extreme fiction at least for me uh where
look are you trying to like say
something with all of this uh you know
going all of this way like you know
breaking all these uh boundaries and
stuff like that are you trying to say
something with it or are you just trying
to like be shocking for attention or be
shocking for shocking's sake
which
that you know what i mean so it's a very
very fine line and i think that
everybody's line for that will be
different i definitely do think this
book had something to say
and the fact that it was so revolting
and was meant to be revolting did
actually like
sort of like feed into the plot to some
extent like feed into the theme of it
some people did not think that if you go
to the goodreads page uh actually a lot
of the view a lot of the reviews
surprisingly are like really really good
uh but then you know there's some that
are just like one or two stars that are
just like nope
you know what i mean and uh what was the
point of this it was just like filthy
and disgusting uh with no purpose i
don't think that it was for no purpose i
have read some stuff before that was
just like shocking or gross like just to
be shocking and gross like it didn't
really mean anything um and i don't
think that's the case here that said
this book is definitely not for everyone
in fact this book is probably
for less than one percent of people
i mean because this [ __ ] was nasty and i
don't like i don't mind um
for some reason i'm not bothered by like
you know extreme fiction transgressive
fiction whatever you want to call it i'm
not bothered at all by
gore in the sense of
you know just evisceration i'm not
grossed out by reading about that at all
i'm not generally grossed out by seeing
it like in movies if it's fake obviously
actually yeah i can probably i can watch
real surgeries and stuff like that but
uh i am grossed out by anything having
to do with poop and anything having to
do with vomit and
to a lesser extent stuff having to do
with like pee
uh particularly people eating it so this
book has
a lot of that okay so know that going in
i mean that's not the only thing that it
has it has like a lot of gore
slaughterhouse type stuff too but
there's a lot a lot
of uh [ __ ] eating
and uh just grungy
yucky crap in general uh bestiality
uh let's see what else
baby killing like self-abortion what
else is in there there's just everything
okay just everything all the trigger
warnings for everything rape uh yeah
everything is in this book uh so
please don't say that i didn't warn you
because yeah this is gross and honestly
i had to like skim through some of this
stuff because this did like make me gag
like several times
like i said mostly the [ __ ] eating which
i'm too i my imagination is too vivid to
like read stuff like that because i can
just picture it i could smell it and i'm
just kind of like
no okay
i have to like step away from the
computer for a minute like where i was
reading it because i was like i think i
might hurl i didn't hurl when i was
reading this i think some people uh that
i've seen reviews of it said they did
actually hurl and uh i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna get on your case about that
because i did kind of feel like i was
gonna hurl a few times and uh so i just
kind of i was like okay i'm just gonna
skim through this section i got it i got
the gist you know what i'm saying uh but
yeah so what is this book about this
book actually came out in 1994 i believe
it was his first novel
and uh so it's kind of like it's pretty
well known from what i could determine
in the quote-unquote transgression
transgressive fiction a lot of which i
feel like came out in the 1990s
i feel like that was a big like splatter
point because i certainly read a lot of
it during that uh time
uh although like i said i kind of prefer
the more gory [ __ ] as opposed to like
the poop and vomit stuff like it's you
know what i mean it's just i don't know
it just really gets to me more than gore
does you can do all kind of [ __ ] with
gore and it doesn't bother me at all but
the minute you start like eating poop
yep i'm i'm kind of out so i'm just
warning you right here there's a really
really lot of [ __ ] eating and just just
disgusting i mean okay i'll get into it
so
uh
so here's what the book is about because
it is it does actually have a story it
is about something it's not just a a
cavalcade of revolting images although
it is that uh but i will say that as
gross as it was i feel like it gets a
little bit less gross as it goes on i
don't know if that's because i was just
getting desensitized to it which that
might be the case
or
if you know he just kind of like wanted
to start out with all like all this
[ __ ] filth at first and then to kind
of
i don't know weed out people that we're
gonna then kind of get to the story
later like i said it's gross all the way
through but
i feel like it got less gross as it went
on maybe i don't know but it's hard for
me to say it's maybe that's subjective
so
this uh this is a book he's a british
author i believe so the main character
of this is a 25 year old young man named
steven
he lives in an apartment with his mother
the mother is never named she is just
called the hag beast
now this woman has uh you presume
been
emotionally and probably physically
abusing uh this young man for his entire
life
she is a hugely fat woman who apparently
never
showers never cleans anything never
anything i mean she this is
okay so this is like pretty gross but
she does like just walk around in this
disgusting
uh like house dress or something like
that that has like menstrual blood like
crusted on the back of it she's just
like you know what i mean and he's like
always talking about how like just she
has various crusts on her we'll say that
uh so she one of her big things too is
that she
feeds him just the most disgusting food
like she will just like slop
like
livers or tripe or something like that
like onto a plate like rare
rare like raw and like just make him eat
it it's almost kind of like this weird
battle of wills
and uh he hates her obviously um but he
i guess they so they have like this
really [ __ ] up relationship they just
live in this filthy hole of an apartment
he also his only friend really is his
dog who's named dog uh and this is like
released oh there's cruelty to animals
in this too by the way uh so just in
case i didn't mention that because i did
give all the trigger warnings any
anything you can think of
is in here pretty much so
so i don't know like i'll get into some
specific stuff but pretty much anything
you can think of hey is this in here yes
it is so dog uh is like probably the
saddest character because at some point
the hagbees the mom
uh she hates the dog obviously because
she's the worst and she threw a brick at
the dog and like crippled its bag legs
so now it can only like walk around like
with its little back legs uh kind of
trailing along behind it
so uh steven has never had a job prior
to now uh he basically spends his days
in this filthy ass apartment with his
disgusting mother
watching tv
and his big dream is he wants to
live like everyone else in this like or
at least the families that he sees on tv
so he wants the whole idealized fantasy
of you know i want a wife who loves me
and cooks for me and i come home from
work every day and she kisses me and we
have a dog and children and white picket
fence he wants all of that type of stuff
um but doesn't really know how to go
about getting it because
he
is not like other people and his mom
like tells him that kind of stuff too
those people they're not like us and all
this other stuff so he doesn't really
know how to go about it he has another
sort of friend
uh there's this girl named lucy and she
lives in an apartment like upstairs
lucy's thing she's kind of a tragic
character as well lucy believes
that
everything like every bad thing um in
the world or like evil essentially
is in physical form like inside of
people's bodies like in these
she kind of describes it like little
black rocks or something like that
so she has made it her life's work to
basically like cut open or vivisect
animals
looking for these
you know rocks like of evil essentially
and she also like likes to go inside her
own body too so there's like a really
gross scene where her and steven are
having sex and she has like a rectal
probe like upper body it's like yeah so
it's a thing it's a whole thing so
there's that i don't want to get it too
much into it because i'm sure this video
is going to get demonetized but because
it's like so i don't want to like
explain it too much but i mean it is
going to come out so yeah so she's like
kind of obsessed with that and because
she's the essentially the only girl that
stephen knows um he's got it in his mind
well he's gonna marry her and we're
gonna have children and everything's
gonna be beautiful and happy and
everything like that
so he ends up getting a job
at a slaughterhouse of course and uh
he's he's originally put like at the end
of the line now the guy that runs the
slaughterhouse is named crips and he is
just this depraved his whole thing is
you can't be a man
until you've learned like just to kill
with impunity whether it's cows or
people or whatever so at this
slaughterhouse he um
pretty much he will just like rape all
the people that work there and like
nobody seems all that upset about it
like while somebody's working at the
machine he'll just come up and like you
know [ __ ] anally rape them and you
know everyone's just kind of like okay
with it
uh also he has these things where like
at some times after at the end of the
day like some of the other workers will
come there and they will bring in a cow
like into the on the killing floor and
they will
like shoot it through
full of holes and then all of them will
like rape the holes and then like one
guy like likes to have the cow [ __ ] on
him like he gets off on that so it's a
whole thing like i said
so there's cow rape there's all kind of
crazy [ __ ]
so uh at some point stephen
sort of
even though this kind of like grosses
him out but he's also kind of like well
maybe crips is right like maybe i do
have to like kill like man up to get
what i want so he starts to think well i
need to kill my mother uh so that you
know i can have the life that i want
so he initially tries to start doing it
subtly
uh by poisoning her by essentially
[ __ ] on a plate and making her eat
it or like asking her to eat it now
again because there's this weird
relationship between the two of them she
knows what he's trying to do so she's
just like well i'm just gonna eat it
then so then they're both like so that
sequence is like really even like just
thinking about it like talking about it
um is making me kind of nauseated so
let's move on uh but yeah so after a
while
he kind of realizes that well she's on
to me it's not working fast enough like
she's not getting sick enough so he
decides he's gonna have to take a more
direct route uh so he ends up doing that
so he does actually end up killing his
mom
and uh getting lucy to move into the
apartment with him and they actually for
a little while they actually do
clean up the apartment uh he has the job
at the um at the
slaughterhouse still but i think like
for a while like he doesn't go back so
it looks as though
crips the guy at the um slaughterhouse
was right he's like oh well i'm a man
now like i killed uh i killed my mother
i got her out of the way and now i have
like this idyllic life because now they
have this apartment now he has a wife uh
his wife gets pregnant
and uh you know and so there's well they
don't get married but you know what i
mean uh and then he's like so we're
gonna have this perfect life just like
the people on tv even though obviously
he is very damaged lucy is very damaged
um and you know it's not gonna end well
now into this
there is also an element of because i've
got into this yet about the cows into
this comes an element of magical realism
because while he is at the
slaughterhouse
he gets uh
kind of he hears like a voice like
talking to him from like underneath like
this uh what a drain or something like
that and down there there is a cow a
guernsey
and it can talk
and he basically says hey we're like a
group of cows that escaped from this
slaughterhouse
and we are witness we witnessed like all
of the cruelties that crips um you know
kind of inflicted on our people you know
on the other cows and we want to kill
him and we want you to help us
so
uh so stephen then gets
sort of uh
you know he kind of goes and hangs out
like with these cows and they live like
underneath the
street like in the sewers and stuff and
there's like a herd of them that live
down there
and him and the guernsey kind of like uh
plot to like kill crips and then he then
stephen kind of gets into this thing too
where
it's almost kind of like the cows are
better than the humans but then like
they're also kind of like savage and
degenerating just like the humans are
and then there's like this power
struggle between stephen the human and
the cow the guernsey who
you know the guernsey says you know the
cows we should live free down here and
we should uh brutalize humans the way
they've brutalized us all this time and
uh you know and so stephen kind of wants
to take over like the cow
herd uh but then the guernsey was like
well no you're a human you this isn't
your place and stuff like that so
there's kind of like a weird like power
struggle going on
down there with the cows as well
so
as i mentioned uh so there is kind of
like
there is an underlying point or there is
an underlying theme to the story uh in
the sense of
you know what i took from it at least
was
to what extent does
violence or power
is it predicated on
uh
brutalizing others
um so there is like a lot of that going
on in there
so
so i do think there's a point to all the
filth and disgustingness i'm not sure if
there was a point to all the [ __ ] eating
other than
just making it as depraved as possible
and also i think that
sort of made it
that steven the character
he had lived like that for so long
that
was there really any like he was
probably so damaged by all of that like
was there any way for him ever to have a
normal life so i in a way i found this
of kind of sad
and it's also kind of like
it's kind of funny too but like in that
weird like blackly humorous like dry
british way but so i don't know
because the humor is like very very
subtle and i think like a lot of
americans if they read it wouldn't
really necessarily think it was funny
but
i don't know i kind of i think i have
more of like an appreciation for like
that kind of dry british humor so to me
it's not laugh out loud funny but it was
kind of like droll funny if you want to
like say it like that but as i said i
also kind of found it like a really
tragic story
because of the way that this
young man
has been brought up you know he really
doesn't have a chance of having like a
regular life just because of all this
like his life is just essentially one
big long catalog of filth and depravity
and would there be any way to get out of
that and it's kind of sad too because
he so he's also very vulnerable and he's
open to like all these people like crips
who are basically well you just have to
like learn to kill with impunity because
he does end up killing you know not only
cows but he ends up killing people as
well um you know to get power
uh and you know so he's vulnerable to
falling into that kind of trap of you
know making him seem like he has to
brutalize others the way he's been
brutalized so i think that's why that's
how his story like mirrors that of the
cows uh so it's kind of like give me a
little bit of an animal farm vibe too i
guess because of the talking cows and
stuff so and i'm pretty sure that was
deliberate
but yeah so as i mentioned if you are at
all squeamish about anything please
please do not read this uh i can't like
recommend it to anybody just like across
the board obviously um but if you're
into kind of more extreme fiction
transgressive transgressive fiction and
you don't mind
uh just a pretty much constant i mean
it's not a long book it's probably only
about 200 pages but it's just like a
constant disgusting just everything like
like i said everything is in this
there's not only [ __ ] eating there's
just vomiting there's crusts of various
kinds there's weird sexual [ __ ] there's
bestiality there's self-abortion there's
like
knifing like
nailing babies to walls [ __ ] like that
so this has everything in it and i would
totally understand if you didn't want to
read it and honestly
i'm not gonna say i wish i didn't read
it i'm actually glad i did read it um
but i will say that it is probably the
most disgusting thing that i've ever
read interestingly i was watching i
found this new uh book reviewing channel
the other day and he did a series i
can't remember what his name is but um
he did a series of the most disturbing
books that he'd ever read which not is
not necessarily like disgusting but so
he done like a long-term series of that
but he did do and i watched a video that
he did earlier today um of the most
disgusting books as in viscerally
discussed like this
and i was very interested he did like a
top ten
this wasn't even in the top ten it was
in like the the honorable mentions
so
so this isn't the most disgusting book
ever written by a long shot i've read a
couple grosser things in this but
i will say that this was
easily easily one of the grossest things
i've ever read i mean really really
gross so if that sounds like a fun time
to you then uh by all means pick it up
and uh give it a read it is kind of like
a like i said sort of a minor classic in
the uh
in the realms of extreme fiction uh so
if you feel like you have to read it
just know going in that
yeah it's it's it's rough you know it's
it's pretty rough and uh that's that's a
lot coming from me because i can i can
deal with a lot but this this one i was
kind of a couple times i was like oh
you know what i mean i was just like man
i just i don't know if i could finish
this but i did want to finish it because
i did i wanted to see where it was going
especially once the talking cows were
introduced i was kind of like oh okay
this is now i'm intrigued let's see
what's going on with that so i was
compelled to like finish it i never
wanted to like just be like [ __ ] no i
don't want to i did kind of think about
it vaguely like toward the beginning
because i'm like oh my god is this like
all leading up to something it's like i
think i'm gonna barf but like i said
once the cat once the talking cows got
introduced i kind of got more interested
in it but uh but yeah so if you want to
read it um you know obviously you can
order the paperback or if you have
kindle unlimited like i do uh you can
read it on there for free or at least
you could as of this recording so if
you've read it and i know one of you has
because one of you recommended it so
thanks i guess i'm not really sure
it was a good book but
but yeah this is pretty sick uh but yeah
so if you've read it let me know what
you think about it in the comments what
you think about this type of extreme
fiction in general like i said i don't
mind it um but there's a fine line
between
you know
i'm being like disgusting like to make a
point or i'm just being disgusting
because i'm an edge lord and i want to
make everybody uncomfortable um
or for attention or whatever
so you know kind of let me know where
you fall on that spectrum because that's
something that i'm actually kind of
interested in uh so yeah that will do it
for this tomes of terror and i will see
you guys on the next one
bye